انطلقت اليوم في الرياضه اكبر فعاليات امن
سبراني في المنطقه واللي هي بلاك هاد
الفعاليه بتستمر من 15 نوفمبر لغايه 17
نوفمبر وبتجمع افضل العقول في مجال الامن
السيبراني ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياض
بالشراكه مع هيئه الترفيه وبتنظيم ايضا من
الاتحاد السعودي للامن السيبراني والبرمجه
والدرونز وشركات انف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بلاكات راح يضم اكثر من 200 متحدث عالمي
من 40 دوله حول العالم 50 شركه امن سبراني
رائده وشركات ناشئه ايضا وتحديات ودورات
ومسابقات جوائز كلها بتصب قيمتها
مليون ريال كلها هذا او كل هذا راح يكون
ضمن الفعاليات
ولا نعرف المزيد مشاهدينا تنضم الينا الان
مراسله العربيه شهد المتروك اهلا بك يا
شهد معنا شهد حطينا اكثر عن بلاك هاد شو
هي الفعاليات اللي بينظمها كيف كانت نسبه
المشاركه لانه من المتوقع انه يكون في
مئات الالاف يعني
الزوار في خلال بلاكات على مدايا يومين
دعم راويه اولا مساء الخير يعني اليوم نحن
متواجدين في معرض بلاك هات وهو اول يوم
لهذا المعرض والذي سيستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام
نتواجد فيه تحديدا في واجهه الرياض ااا
يعني اللي لاحظناه من بدايه دخولنا لهذا
المعرض وهو الازدحام الكبير خصوصا في هذه
الثلاثه
اليوم الواحد همم لان الازدحام جدا كبير
حتى في الخارج هناك الكثير من المهتمين
بمجال الامن السيبراني والتكنولوجيا
والمعلومات همم هناك الكثير من الشركات
المتخصصه بالامن الاسبراني المشاركه في
هذا المعرض روي ساخذك في جوله قصيره همم
يعني ربما لا تعطي حق هذا المعرض كثيره
همم لكن هذا هو المعرض بشكل هناك تواجد
كبير للاشخاص والزوار وحتى المش ممكن اا
في معرض بلاك هات طبعا معرض بلاك هات هو
من ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياضي هذا العام
2022 همم مستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام في الكثير
من الشركات التي تقوم بعمل ايضا دورات
تدريبيه هناك تفاعل مع حتى زوار المعرض
والمهتمين بمجال الامن همم السيبراني هناك
تفاعل كبير من حيث يعني مشاركه المعلومات
استخدام الاجهزه الموجوده في هذا المعرض
والتي تعرضها ايضا الشركات همم المشاركه
ايضا هناك دورات تدريبيه تقوم بها هذه
الشركات هناك متحدثين بارزين طبعا في همم
هذا المعرض والذي طبعا سيستمر لمده ثلاثه
ايام كل يوم راح يكون همم في متحدثين
مختلفين في هذا المجال اللي هو الامن
السيبراني والتكنولوجيا والمعلومات طبعا
يعني السعوديه تحاول ان همم يعني تثبت
مكانتها في همم يعني همم يعني اهتمامها
بالتكنولوجيا والامن السيبراني خصوصا في
المنطقه ومن خلال طبعا موسم الرياض تبرز
هذه الفعاليات وهذا ما نلاحظه في معرض
بلاك هات همم يعني الذي انطلق اليوم ولمده
ثلاثه ايام
وهناك سمعنا في بعض الجوائز ايضا
والمسابقات وجوائز للفائزين
صحيح اليوم همم يعني همم
تصل الى مليون ريال سعودي للمشاركين
والذين ينضمون الى همم يعني فعاليات اللي
تقام في هذا المعرض بالتالي سيكون هناك
اهتمام اكبر مشاركه اكبر من يعني الشركات
وايضا زوار هذا المعرض شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسله العربيه شهد المتروك كانت معنا من
مقر معرض بلاك هاد في الرياض
[موسيقى]